is there a libertarian case for vaccine
mandates george mason university law
professor ilya soman supports vaccine
mandates in certain cases because he
believes they're a relatively small
infringement on freedom and are
preferable to harm reduction strategies
like mass mandates and lockdowns which
he sees as posing a greater threat to
our liberties angela mcardle the chair
of the libertarian party of los angeles
county says she'll actively work to
destroy any institution that tries to
enforce a vaccine passport and is
currently launching legal challenges to
overturn vaccine mandates in california
and new york on wednesday september 8th
someone and micarta went head-to-head at
the soho forum in new york city soman
took the affirmative and mcardle the
negative on the resolution while vaccine
mandates are an infringement on freedom
some are justified due to their big
payoff in lives saved the debate was
moderated by soho forum director gene
epstein
while vaccine mandates are an
infringement on freedom some are
justified due to their big payoff in
lives saved and here to defend the
resolution to take the affirmative elias
sewmen ilya please come to the stage
[Applause]
taking the negative on the resolution
angela mcardle
angela please come to the stage
[Applause]
okay um i'm gonna yield uh the podium to
you ilya you have 15 minutes
to defend the resolution uh take it away
ilya you'll be timed in the audience and
uh we'll be warning you
take the party
i'd like to start by thanking gene and
the soho forum for organizing this event
and all of you for coming
and i'll also say my name is ilya silman
and i'm the guy that was stupid enough
to come and defend vaccine mandates in
front of a mostly libertarian audience
fools rush in where wise men fear to
tread and this may be an example of that
phenomenon however my task is easier
than it looks at first sight and that's
so for a couple of reasons one is the
resolution doesn't say that i have to
defend all vaccine mandates of any kind
just that some of them
are justified because they save lots of
lives and second the key point about
vaccine mandates is that they're
actually a very small burden only a very
small imposition on liberty and in some
contexts i emphasize the word some they
can save a lot of lives and in fact they
are much smaller
burdens and have a bigger payoff uh than
even some infringements on liberty that
most libertarians accept uh in other
contexts uh so i'm gonna start off uh
with what i think is actually a
relatively easy case and that is the
defense of vaccination mandates when
they're imposed in the private sector or
on people like myself government
employees uh so we have seen both would
covet but even before then that some
private employers require their
employees to get vaccinated uh for
various diseases particularly in the
health care sector but sometimes
elsewhere as well similarly there are
universities and other types of venues
that require students for customers to
get vaccinations once again this long
predates covid but obviously it's
happened under covet as well and i think
this is very easily defended on even the
purest of libertarian grounds this is
private organizations deciding for
themselves who they want to associate
with and moreover the restriction when
it deals with vaccinations for deadly
contagious diseases it's one that helps
ensure the safety
of their employees and customers
and so forth i knew you can make a
similar point with respect to government
requirements for government employees
including yes state university
professors like myself i have to be
vaccinated not just for the covid but
for some other things uh for my job uh
and uh it's standard for employers to be
able to impose burdens as a condition of
employment that uh you might not impose
if you're just attaching it to the
general population and indeed compared
to other burdens of employment this one
is actually a small one i get the jab in
a few minutes i'm done and i go on with
my wife on the other hand another part
of my job is that i have to sit through
faculty meetings much much worse much
more painful much worse for my health
too
but yet if i don't sit through them i
could be penalized or fired similarly
coming to work on time every day is a
bigger burden uh than having to get
vaccinated uh it's even a bigger risk to
your physical health uh on average for
most people you're more likely to die or
be seriously injured in a car accident
on the way to work than you are by
getting vaccinated either for covid19 or
for the other diseases for which there
are sometimes employer vaccination
mandates and on a slightly more serious
note for at least some types of
government employees there's actually a
very strong moral case that they should
be vaccinated for example for the police
and firefighters ordinary citizens often
have no choice about dealing with those
individuals
and therefore
they owe it to us if they're going to do
their duty
to get vaccinated against deadly
contagious diseases i think there's a
similar story for members of the armed
forces
they too often have to deal with people
who have no choice about being in
proximity to them and also if the
soldiers or police or firefighters if
they themselves come down with a deadly
disease that means while they have it
they can't do their duty and they're not
doing the thing that they contractually
signed up to do so that's another reason
to justify the imposition in those cases
so uh just on sort of the low-hanging
fruit uh of my side of this resolution
private mandates for uh they're
voluntarily accepted uh through contract
as a condition of employment or
government mandates on people like
myself govern employees who come in
contact with members of the public
and therefore
risk spreading contagious diseases i
think there's a strong case at the very
least for vaccination mandates in those
situations and that alone i think is
enough to justify the very limited
resolution that we're talking about here
today however i'm going to be a bit more
controversial and risque and point out
that there are going to be some cases
where it is justifiable to impose
mandates yes through the government even
on members of the public who unlike me
do not actually work for the government
or get government paychecks uh the
reason for this again uh is that this is
actually a very small imposition on
liberty you get the jab
you can almost immediately go on with
your normal life there is a small number
of people for whom that's not true
people who suffer unusually great health
risks for whatever reason from getting
vaccinated for those people i totally
agree they should be exempted from
vaccination mandates and in almost all
currently existing mandates or proposed
ones they do have exemptions you you can
argue about and we can discuss in
questions whether there should also be
exemptions for religious objections in
practice there's only a very small
portion of the u.s population at least
that has religious objections to
vaccination
now why is the vaccination justified why
is even a small burden defensible the
reason is that it can save at least in
some contexts many hundreds of lives if
you look at the history of those
contagious diseases that we have gotten
under control measles polio smallpox and
some others every one of them
vaccination played a large role and
sadly in every one of these cases
vaccination mandates also played a
significant role uh we probably could
not have gotten to the point where those
diseases are only very minor threats or
in the case of smallpox completely
eradicated without vaccination mandates
and there's a long
history behind this
notice the resolution does not say you
know that this is only about covet
mandates even if you think that the code
vaccines are too unreliable or otherwise
problematic uh there are still
vaccination mandates and other contexts
for other diseases that have existed for
a long time that could be defensible
and that's all i really need to prove to
show
my limited side of this resolution
however it is also the case to covet
vaccines and yes covet vaccine mandates
do you have a valuable role to play
both in the u.s and around the world the
introduction of vaccines has massively
reduced both mortality from covid and
serious uh hospitalization and disease
from coveting the lake up probably 90
percent or more of the people who are
dying recently uh or going to hospital
recently because of covet in the u.s and
europe uh they're sadly the unvaccinated
moreover the issue is not just
protecting the individuals themselves to
get vaccinate if it was only that i
would be opposed to mandates i don't
think there should be mandates to
protect you from your own bad judgment
however the data also shows pretty
consistently uh that the vaccinated also
risks spreading the disease much less
in both the u.s and data from israel and
elsewhere
a person who gets the covet vaccine
they're about six to ten times less
likely to be infected uh by cove than a
person who doesn't if you control for
other variables
and in addition even if they are
infected they're somewhat less likely to
spread the disease this is data from the
delta variant i fully admit we don't yet
know for sure whether the omicron
variant that just came around is going
to be like this or not uh i think early
data suggests that vaccines still limit
the spread but if it turns out that they
don't i'm perfectly willing to admit uh
that that would weaken the case for
vaccine mandates unless and until we
have
a vaccine that actually does constrain
omicron like it previously constrained
delta and alpha
and others
even with
vaccination mandates that could be
justified it is not my claim uh that
they can be justified in every
conceivable mechanism their
circumstances i'm not in favor of saying
as the government of austria has done
that you know the unvaccinated should be
completely locked up in their houses or
except for a few uh essential purposes
for going out i think we can have more
limited vaccination mandates that are
still
quite effective for example we can
impose them in some instances where you
already have to show id and other proof
to get in why kind of plane flight and
the like alternatively vaccination can
be a requirement of getting certain
kinds of government benefits like
welfare or social security are like or
of parts of them uh from a libertarian
point of view that would be a win-win uh
if the person gets the uh
the the vaccine their don't risk
spreading contagious disease if they
refuse uh at least there's a reduction
in welfare spending uh and uh you know
what's not to like uh about that
particular approach at least from a
libertarian point of view and i don't
even propose you know that the person
lose all benefits or whatnot
you can have a large enough fine that
reduces the benefits and provides a
strong incentive to get vaccinated
there's also a lot of evidence that when
vaccination mandates of various kinds
are imposed they do indeed increase
vaccination rates as we've recently seen
with federal employees
where the evidence shows that some 92
percent of all federal employees have
gotten vaccinated as of the last few
months when there's been a vaccination
mandate and of the remainder
there's another three or four percent
who have health exceptions where you
know it's defensible that they uh not be
required to do so
as always with any kind of government
intervention or sometimes even with
private sector restrictions we should
think about slippery slope risk so i
totally understand the concern that you
know if we have vaccination mandates
maybe that's not in itself terrible but
what will come next uh you can't totally
discount risks like that ever at least
particularly not when you're dealing
with government in this area however it
seems very likely that vaccination
mandates don't pose very much of a
slippery slope risk we know that because
we've already had them for over 200
years dating all the way back to the
revolutionary war
when george washington imposed a
vaccination mandate against smallpox on
his soldiers in the continental army
and the slippery slope effects that we
so far in the last 200 years of
vaccination mandates
have been very modest on the other hand
many of the other measures taken to
combat covid lockdowns school closures
mask mandates
and so forth they're much more
unprecedented
they're much more severe intrusions on
liberty they're also much less effective
in stopping the spread of disease uh but
uh in addition to being bad in
themselves uh they pose much more in the
way of novel slippery slope risks now
you might say to yourself if we had an
ideal libertarian government it wouldn't
impose these other more severe measures
but it wouldn't impose vaccination
mandates either
even if that's true however i would
remind you that
ideal libertarian governments are in
very short supply we don't have them
right now it's very unlikely that we're
going to have them in the near future
not even a speaker as capable as angela
is likely to persuade the world to turn
fully libertarian anytime soon even
though she is indeed a great public
speaker she's very good at what she does
but not even she i think is going to be
up to that particular task so when you
have real world governments of the kind
that we actually have and you have a
deadly pandemic spreading it is very
likely that governments will act in some
way to try to constrain that if they're
not able to constrain it through
vaccination they're likely to adopt
other far worse more restrictive
measures so vaccination is a way to
forestall that and we've already had
some benefits from vaccination in that
respect if you look at the spread of the
delta variant over the last few months
even though it's more
transmissible and virulent than the
previous version we have not had
anything like the same degree of
lockdowns school closures or even mass
mandates in many places that we had with
the initial variable the initial variant
and that's obviously because of the
difference that vaccination has made
that
there's less of a sense of crisis than
there was before because vaccination is
constraining the spread in a way that it
didn't before if we had a higher
vaccination rate
instead of the current 60 if it was 80
or 90 or whatnot uh then we would be
more secure not only against the virus
but also against awful things that
governments might do in response to it
so
i'll end with this point whether you
agree with me about vaccination or not
if you're worried about the fate of
liberty in the coven world you should be
mostly focused on these other much more
restrictive measures lockdowns school
closures travel bans masked mandates and
so forth all of these things restrict
liberty far more than vaccination
mandates do and all of them have much
more in the way of slippery slope risks
as well
so i hope at least we can agree on that
and we can also recognize that
vaccination is one of the tools that can
help prevent these much more severe
infringements on liberty as well as
saving many lives
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
angela mcconnell for the negative angela
please take the podium uh 15 minutes for
the negative take it away angela
within a few minutes i go on with my
life
let me show you something share
something with you
sherry was 13 years old when her father
took her to get the vaccine in august
and she had a reaction to the shot
she was taken to the hospital for
cognitive dysfunction and heart pain
they had to place her a 13 year old girl
on life support
a few days later her condition improved
a little bit and her mother was able to
move her to home for home care she was
verbally unresponsive but able to hold
her mother's hand and communicate with
head nuts
sensing something was off her pet dog
and cat laid beside her nearly every day
and every night she could be seen gently
barely petting both of them a few days
after sharia returned home she had to
get rushed back to the hospital where
her neurologist discovered severe damage
which he had never seen before
sherry's condition stabilized again
so she was released to her mother for
home care with a nurse where she laid
nearly unresponsive
her mother said
at times when i spoke to sherry her
facial expressions confirmed she could
hear me but wasn't able to talk other
times when i sat in the bed with her i
would hold her hand
and she would grasp mine
the last 10 minutes
sherry had a live with her mother she
spoke
her mother tatiana recalls
i had spent the entire day in her room
either laying in bed with her or reading
to her i was talking to her and getting
no verbal reply when the nurse arrived i
decided to go to the kitchen to get a
snack
rufus our dog ran into the kitchen and
whimpered to get my attention
i knew something was wrong
when i got to the room
sherry was struggling with the iv in her
arm and the nurse was trying to restrain
her i told the nurse to let go and
remove the iv temporarily
soon after my daughter became lucid and
was able to speak for the first time
since she received the vaccination and
she said mom my heart hurts and i have a
headache it's going to be okay don't be
angry and don't blame dad i've heard you
talking to me every day i tried and
couldn't wake up to tell you mom
thank you for being my mom
and thank you
[Music]
and thank you for all of my animals
please take care of them mom you were
right there is a heaven but i wanted to
make sure you knew how much i love you
and don't be afraid
soon after this her mother tatiana says
my daughter stopped talking
and she laid quietly in my arms with her
eyes open and a smile while holding my
hand
then her eyes closed
her dog rufus began to whine
and soon after she slipped off asleep in
my arms forever
sherry's permanent pulmonologist and
neurologist affirmed that the
vaccination was the direct reason for
her hospitalization and death and she is
one of the many reasons that i'm here
today to condemn these mandates
we're going to keep the clock going
while we have a brief moment of silence
for sherry and every other child that
died due to these vaccines and this
mandate
thank you
and i got her mother's permission to
share that that's from her
eulogy this debate is profoundly
personal for a lot of people watching
here and at home
if it saves just one life the mandates
are worth it right
the good outweighs the bad let's see if
it does let's see uh let's look at some
some side effect statistics in less than
one year the vera system has reported
eight hundred and seventy five thousand
six hundred and fifty three adverse
reactions to covet vaccines in the us
including one hundred and thirty five
four 400 reports of serious injury and
18
461 deaths
sherry is a statistic now
at what point do we mandate that a
certain percentage of our population be
put to death for the greater good
the average cost of a child's coffin is
about a thousand dollars i looked it up
will that also be covered by governance
subsidies at some point who gets to
decide who lives and dies
this is not a trolley problem thought
experiment there are real lives at stake
most of pfizer's coveted vaccine
contracts include the following clause
and you can look them up purchaser
acknowledges that there may be adverse
effects of the vaccine that are not
currently known
the cdc reports higher than expected
levels of heart inflammation in young
men ages 12 to 24 mostly moderna and
pfizer especially after booster shots 20
of vaccine induced myocarditis cases in
teenagers require icu hospitalization
that is more than the percentage of
young covid patients who require
hospitalization
a june study on pregnant women in the
new england journal of medicine revealed
that eight out of ten women who received
a coveted shot in their first or second
trimester miscarried that's an 81.9
miscarriage rate the normal u.s
miscarriage rate is between 10 and 26
depending on the source
the cdc doesn't grant exemptions to
pregnant women and neither does new york
city your reproductive rights don't
matter neither does the life of your
unborn baby we are mandating
miscarriages
there are no studies confirming the
safety of covid boosters they don't
exist
how can we in good conscience experiment
on coerced pregnant women and unwilling
children
would you look these people in the eye
would you look sherry's mother in the
eye and tell her that covid vaccines
have to be mandated and that your
comfortable sacrificing her child for
the greater good because she was just
one of a few thousand people who died
let's examine the trade-offs
risk getting coveted or
mandate getting a shot that kills a
small percentage of us puts healthy
young men in the hospital with a heart
condition and creates an 80 percent
miscarriage rate if it saves just one
life let's repeal these mandates
how about efficacy do the shots even
work pfizer's covid vaccine contract
states purchaser acknowledges the
long-term effects and efficacy of the
vaccine are not currently known that's a
quote
as of august 30 of the covet cases in la
where i'm from were in vaccinated people
as of august no october 18th
at least 10 857 americans have died of
covet 19 despite being fully vaccinated
that's cdc data all of this is
add
10857 to the 18 461 reported deaths from
the shot that adds up to 29 318 people
who've died after receiving a covet shot
that we know of
it's not safe
or effective
and there's no other vaccine that
requires a six-month booster shot
so the trade-off is now
risk getting covered or
mandate getting a shot every six months
that isn't guaranteed to keep you from
getting sick or dying kills a small
percentage of us puts healthy young men
in the hospital with a heart condition
and creates an 80 miscarriage rate
what about alternative treatments
the government coveted contracts are
designed to suppress other treatments
why are ivermectin and
hydroxychloroquine suppressed and
ridiculed when they are excellent
options for treating covid
ivermectin which acts as an antiviral
anti-parasitic and anti-inflammatory
it's one of the safest drugs available
to human beings
this right here is ivermectin prescribed
to an adult it's not horse paste a
standard dose is 9 to 12 milligrams per
day
a one month supply cost me about 40
dollars because the merck patent on it
expired in 1997.
why do we need mandated vaccines that
don't work when we could just take
ivermectin and afford it
why has the media made such an
aggressive disinformation campaign
against cures that work safely without
deadly side effects
well my friends my friend stephen
consula would say intellectual property
laws allow corporations to monopolize
pharmaceuticals and have a quid pro quo
relationship with the government
pfizer's government contracts don't
allow countries to return vaccines if
the country deems they're too unsafe for
distribution
these contracts cost countries around
the world billions and billions of
dollars our government has a financial
motive to mandate vaccination and make
sure we all comply
our government in the u.s spent over 9
billion on subsidies to pharma companies
to develop vaccines and purchase them
and thanks to the revolving door
cronyism of big pharma and the fda the
biggest pharma firms have control over
the drug approval process and they're
able to prevent smaller companies from
gaining quick approval for safer
alternative treatments
remember fauci did this to aids patients
too you can look that up
there is no need for a vaccine mandate
when there are better affordable
treatment options available so the
trade-off is now risk getting covered or
mandate getting a shot every six months
that isn't guaranteed to keep you from
getting sick or dying kills a small
percentage of us puts healthy young men
in the hospital with a heart condition
creates an 80 miscarriage rate when you
could have taken ivermectin and
recovered faster
well maybe we can just sue the companies
right no you can't vaccine manufacturers
were granted immunity from lawsuits in
1986 in the supreme court case bruce
white's v wife they have no liability
why should they worry about mandates
hurting you when they're never held
accountable in 2009 pfizer paid out a
2.3 billion dollar fraud settlement for
criminal and civil at liability for
beckstra a pain reliever that killed a
lot of people merck paid out 4.85
billion dollars to sell wrongful death
lawsuits over vioxx 88 000 people
suffered heart attacks from vioxx and 38
000 of them died vioxx was recalled the
stats on coveted vaccines are much worse
have to trust pharmaceutical companies
blindly knowing these statistics so now
the trade-off is risk getting covet or
mandate getting a shot every six months
that isn't guaranteed to keep you from
getting sick or dying kills a small
percentage of us puts healthy young men
in the hospital with a heart condition
creates an 80 percent miscarriage rate
and you can't sue if they hurt you even
though their drugs have killed people in
the past when you could have taken
ivermectin instead
what about jobs lost
yesterday's heroes are today's trash
nurses work through the entire pandemic
without vaccines now they're being fired
if they refuse the shot
34 000 new york healthcare workers lost
their jobs due to the mandate
firefighters
fired 26 fire stations in new york city
have been closed because employees have
been fired for refusing the shot same
stats in la same stats is the mandate
keeping you safe no it's terminating
nurses firefighters and paramedics and
putting your safety at risk
small businesses were destroyed over
lockdowns they're being hit again by
vaccine mandates the lockdowns wiped out
one third of all of the small businesses
in new york city and in new jersey
vaccine mandates are continuing that
trend they're not reversing it
mandating the vaccine doesn't get us
closer to normal and it doesn't make us
freer we've gone from two weeks to
flatten the curve to lock down to just
wear a mask to take the vaccine to take
the booster to keep wearing your mask to
permanent mass mandates in oregon to
show us your vaccine card next it is
going to be forcible vaccination it is
all grossly unconstitutional as you know
as elia also knows do we need conversive
medical procedures to have a safer freer
society the head of the eu recently
stated she's in favor of mandatory
vaccinations not just mandates to
exclude you from businesses forcible
injection
these mandates are not making us freer
they're not getting us back to normal by
any stretch australia has set up covid
internment camps that happened after the
mandates
normal has never met mandating vaccines
for a respiratory virus under coercion
with a vaccine that has no long-term
safety profile there are no studies
confirming the safety of covet boosters
this is in defiance of everything we
know about epidemiology it's not normal
the intention behind the mandates
british columbia parks and rec
departments stated remember the purpose
of the vaccine card is to incentivize
residents to get vaccinated not to
control the spread of the virus virus
spread is controlled through vaccination
physical distancing masking hand hygiene
by limiting a variety of discretionary
activities to those who are vaccinated
we expect to increase the inoculation
coverage to a safe range for resuming
full societal activities
it really is a to create an incentive to
improve our vaccination coverage the
vaccine passport is for non-essential
opportunities and it's really to create
an incentive to get higher vaccination
rates do i need to review the trade-offs
again
these mandates were decreed out of
contempt for human life mandating this
vaccine makes absolutely no sense these
mandates are an attack on personal
freedom medical innovation property
rights free market capitalism and the
right of peaceful people to move about
freely
the mandates reduce your existence and
worth as a human being to just one
question are you vaccinated your hard
work and experience your education your
intellect all of its cast aside it's
replaced with a single question about
your private medical history your health
status doesn't matter perfect health
natural immunity already had it
vaccinated whatever it is
immunocompromised fertility concerns
blood clots risk of stroke doesn't
matter it's just if you're vaccinated
all that matters is the shot
this mandate and everything that came
before it has created a culture of
coercion and this kind of callus
utilitarianism never results in the
greater good it claims
ben franklin was correct when he said if
you give up your liberty for security
you will get neither there is no
scenario where giving up your right to
make your own medical decisions will
result in a safer world australia and
canada have made that very clear
this is a lot like the failed war on
terror we're mandating a drug that kills
a small percentage of us that
dehumanizes the rest of us and we're
excusing it because we think it keeps us
safe when in fact it does not and even
if it did we have no right to sentence a
small percentage of the population all
innocent people to social ostracization
or death as scott horton would say come
on man that's [ __ ]
your obedience is prolonging this
nightmare there is no justification for
these deadly dehumanizing mandates and
for these reasons i oppose them all of
them thank you
thank you angela uh five minutes of
rebuttal ilya
it's interesting that angela chose to
quote benjamin franklin benjamin
franklin was a person whose i think four
or five-year-old son died of smallpox
because franklin made the mistake of not
getting him vaccinated uh which franklin
then regretted for the rest of his life
and during the revolutionary war when
george washington mandated vaccination
against smallpox for the continental
army uh benjamin franklin was very much
in favor of that but i'm not going to
say you know i should win this debate
because franklin was on my side
rather the reason why i think this side
of resolution is better
is more fundamental even if every single
thing she said is accurate about the
covet vaccine that doesn't change the
fact that at least some uh vaccination
mandates are justified i mentioned lots
of examples throughout history of
contagious deadly diseases that were
eradicated or gotten under control in
considerable part through vaccination
mandates smallpox measles
many polio many others
but it is also the case that most of
what she said about the coveted vaccine
just simply isn't true if you look
around the world uh in places where you
get higher vaccination rates that has
massively reduced the death rate from
covet in the hospitalization rate and
this is wide we agreed in the scientific
community there was only government
officials saying this they might say
fine maybe they're lying or they have
ulterior motives but this is widely
agreed both by governmental scientists
and private sector scientists as well
and it's backed by data on the effects
of the vaccines both in the u.s and
around the world so either there's a
great conspiracy of scientists
all over the world that are hiding the
truth from us or we should accept the
evidence that they put forward to it and
also the evidence of our eyes which is
that people who are vaccinated have
vastly lower rates of both infection and
death
and also
hospitalization awaken people who are
not yes it's true a few thousand people
in the us have died of the covid despite
already being vaccinated most of them
elderly and with very serious
co-morbidities that's a vastly lower
death rate
by about 10 or 20 fold than the death
rate among the unvaccinated and the same
thing is true elsewhere around the world
now the issue of side effects angela
cited the va ers data
that is a junk database anybody can go
online and report anything they want
into that database and there's no
quality control there
when you actually look at controlled
studies and evidence conducted by actual
scientific researchers they consistently
find
that the side effect rates from the
covid are extremely low
and indeed it's much safer than all
sorts of other activities we take every
day statistically speaking for the
overwhelming majority of people they
take a much greater risk of death or
serious injury if they have to drive a
couple miles to get vaccinated
than from getting the vaccine itself
she mentioned the issue of myocarditis
and the of
heart problems for young men yes there's
a slightly higher incidence of heart
problems in that group
than in others even so it's actually
rest in the incidence of myocarditis
from getting the covid
among that same age group
and it's also less than the risk of a
given young man
you know
being being killed or injured in a car
accident or other normal life activities
uh and the same story could be told
about pretty much all the uh other
specific technical scientific points she
makes ultimately neither angela nor i
are scientists
neither of us are conducting our own
original research on the effects of
vaccines i think on technical questions
of that kind
those of us who are not experts we have
to look
to the scientific community who are and
in this case there's a pretty broad
consensus there which is not just
limited to government scientists or
others who have a specific narrow
self-interest involved
ultimately
i think the key point is this there are
some situations where vaccine mandates
are justified because they can save
large numbers of lives at little cost
where that is not the case then i oppose
the mandates too it is not my purpose
under this resolution to defend every
conceivable mandate
in every conceivable circumstance
moreover while taking the vaccine is not
without risk
it's actually a lower risk that even
libertarians accept to preserve innocent
wives
in other contexts
having a police force or an army to
protect us against criminals or foreign
attack that creates risks sometimes the
police will abuse people paying taxes to
support those entities
that's much more of a burden on liberty
than taking the vaccine
we can can and should have various
constraints on the police and the armed
forces to reduce the threat that they
pose but even at its best it's going to
be a higher threat
than that posed by at least some vaccine
mandates
so ultimately
i think this is a very limited
resolution
all i have to show is that some vaccine
mandates in some contexts are justified
and i think i've been able to do that
thank you so much
thank you elia um
five minutes to refine it from you
angela
thank you for those alternative facts
you can look up all the information you
want on side effects it's finally
hitting mainstream news it is undeniable
in addition to working in litigation
before i did this i worked as an
assistant medical researcher for dr
pearl grimes who was michael jackson's
dermatologist i do know how to look at
medical research i am experienced with
that and i was paid to do it
professionally
smallpox was on the decline starting in
1800 before the vaccine
became mainstream and white and was
widely spread that is verifiable
information the same goes for polio
polio was on the decline before the
vaccine actually hit it and made uh i
mean
became widely available and that is in
alignment with something called far's
law which is basically the bell curve of
disease and recovery this is all widely
available information i will not shill
for private sector mandates private
sector mandates are just like government
mandates they're based upon government
propaganda and fear-mongering and
government subsidies of course people
are going to listen when it's all over
the news and they're going to follow the
government's orders when the government
is terrifying them uh my heart goes out
to government employees i have been
helping the la department of sanitation
trying try to overturn the mandate since
their union isn't helping them
let's not forget that members of the
armed forces were experimented on and
made very sick by the anthrax vaccine
several years ago the same thing is
happening right now and i will discuss
that in my clothes epidemiology has
basically been turned upside down and
common sense has been tossed out the
window because at risk people are still
being forced to take the shot so it
doesn't matter if you're at risk or not
all of a sudden doctors are afraid to
speak out against it you're in a lot of
risk right now and it's all because
government has a financial incentive to
to force people to take these shots and
so do the hospitals and doctors who have
purchased all of these
all these drugs
as a libertarian i don't believe in
welfare but i do oppose punishing poor
people for exercising medical autonomy
again so many alternative treatments are
available in the past 150 years billions
of people have been pulled up out of
poverty through the spread of free
market enterprise and personal liberty
we've seen communist empires fall
some suddenly and others slowly as
people around the world have embraced
free market capitalism and fought for a
freer more prosperous world for their
children now we're seeing all of those
beautiful advances for the human
condition snuffed out into darkness
shuttered bankrup businesses
bankruptcies suicides vaccine mandates
are not the way to get rid of lockdowns
vaccine mandates are the next
manifestation of extreme government
control and bowing to these mandates
will bring about the next escalation and
mandates which will be removing children
from their unvaccinated parents
enforceable vaccination of a dangerous
drug that has no midterm or long-term
safety studies
all this misery all these side effects
these horror stories all the small
businesses close bankruptcies broken
dreams it's only going to increase if we
allow these mandates to go into effect
67 of la's black population is
unvaccinated are we going to seriously
refuse a majority of black people to
enter public businesses are we back to
that did you know medical malpractice is
the third leading cause of death in the
united states they're supposed to be the
highest level professionals but they
injure and kill us all the time
if government mandates vaccines for our
health shouldn't they also issue an
emergency order to curb or halt all of
the malpractice deaths what happened to
if it saves just one life
i don't need to go through the trade-off
again we can sue doctors but not vaccine
manufacturers the american heart
association just released a study that
shows the mnr mrna vaccine dramatically
increases endothelial inflammation
markers that's the cells in your
arteries
how many more damning studies will it
take before we refuse to mandate these
shots
the drive for total vaccination has been
placed before all other values in
society apparently including individual
rights public safety and employment for
working class americans if you can't say
no to a mandate that rips apart the
fabric of our society and creates a
medical caste system
you're definitely not a libertarian
and i don't believe that you care about
the special intrinsic value of each
human life
vaccine mandates are a dangerous and
gross violation of freedom and there is
no justification for them historically
it doesn't matter if some other person
that we've heard of said that they were
a good idea they're a bad idea now and
they always have been and we are seeing
how they are ruining people's lives
if you're watching remotely and you're
working to oppose these mandates make
sure you drop a link to your website or
social media in the live stream comments
because we all need to work together to
fight this stuff
and happy birthday barbara olivestod i'm
done
uh thank you angela we we now go to the
q a uh part of the evening we're gonna
accept questions from the live streamers
and we have a microphone uh corner there
it's uh pretty dark i can't quite see it
but it is over in the corner and so if
you want to line up to ask your
questions please do so uh first i want
to make a statement as moderator uh in
terms of the wording of the resolution
uh
certainly elia was quite correct to say
that
it talks about maxine vaccine mandates
generally and and it does say that some
are justified and therefore it's open to
interpreting it to mean 200 years ago
they were justified and that is true as
far as it goes i will leave it open to
you
possibly to say that when a vaccine
mandate resolution is debated especially
in new york city at a time when vaccine
mandates with respect to covet are being
imposed that the part of illya's uh
defense would had which had to do with
defending covert mandates may be
relevant to the resolution according to
your interpretation i will make that
judgment since we are living very much
in an age and in a city of uh vaccine
mandates but that aside um having made
that judgment i want to use moderators
prerogative to ask a question uh first
of you ilya
we do have it's been estimated possibly
as many as 100 million people who've
already had covet
and who have according to the judgment
of many uh professionals developed
natural immunity and so there are those
who say to me
i have natural immunity and
the question as to whether a vaccine on
top of having natural immunity
necessarily helps or hurts is uh is up
in the air
to those people who have natural
immunity
let's put a finer point on it might they
at least be asked well if you show up at
a venue like this or at a job
to do job with with other people might
they at least just be asked uh pass the
covet test do you think that then to put
a finer point on it that vaccine meant
that should
necessarily be imposed on people who
could show that they had covert and
therefore have natural immunity
so the question of natural immunity is
one that as i understand it divides
scientific experts among themselves uh
if it is the case that national immunity
limits the spread of the virus in
roughly the same way as vaccination does
then i fully grant that for a person who
has that kind of mass community a
vaccination mandate would be unnecessary
or unjustified i would say that when it
comes to private organizations like this
one uh that would still be a judgment
that they can make for themselves they
can say you know in our venue we want
everybody to vaccinate even if they also
have national immunity because there is
also data from israel and elsewhere
which says that natural immunity plus
vaccination prevents the spread more
than one alone so at the very least
private organizations here to judge that
for themselves but when it comes to
government bodies imposing on the
general population that i think if
natural immunity is equivalent to
vaccine abuse community then
if vaccine induced immunity is
sufficient then likewise national
communities should be sufficient but i'm
reluctant to
judge the facts on that issue too much
because this is another question sort of
a technical question of epidemiology i'm
not an epidemiologist or a doctor or
scientific researcher in this area on
those kinds of technical questions it
makes sense uh to listen to the experts
in the field even though the experts uh
we should not defer them on fundamentals
oh excuse me
got a money
you should be using the microphone i'm
sorry
uh
sorry
i didn't realize i was supposed to be
holding the microphone in my mind yeah
i'm not an expert on microphones but
yeah uh
i should have been it's my it's my so to
say everything again would you would you
review your answer did that you know how
to summarize it now that you've done it
okay so i apologize to people in person
who have already heard everything it's
my opinion
but uh
what i was saying is that the issue of
natural immunity and the extent of
protection it provides this is something
that experts disagree on there are some
who believe that
the degree of protection is the same as
that for vaccination if so then
obviously there's no need for
vaccination mandates for those who have
that level of natural immunity there are
others who argue particularly with the
omicron variant
that
natural immunity is much weaker than
vaccine protection and there's also some
evidence that the combination of both
natural immunity and vaccine protection
gives you more than
either one alone does the final point i
would make on this that when it is that
when it comes to private organizations
uh and private individuals uh they
should be able to decide for themselves
uh whether uh
entry into our business or our
organization or whatnot should require
uh vaccination
and it was interesting to me to hear and
usa well even with the private sector
she seems to think that even they should
not be allowed to decide for themselves
whether they want vaccination
requirements in their venues or not i
would have thought the sort of basic
principles of freedom of association uh
would let different organizations uh
decide for themselves on that uh and
that uh we cannot just simply assume
that people who might differ with us on
that question that you know they've just
been scared by the government especially
not on an issue where uh private sector
scientists uh they don't differ with the
would govern employed ones very much on
this question of the effectiveness of
vaccines and the deadlines of the
disease
uh comment uh angela in that response oh
absolutely yeah i didn't say that you
shouldn't be allowed
to decide who comes into your building i
think it's a bad stupid idea and i won't
shill for it or say
uh i won't carry water for it just like
i won't say i won't go out in public and
say oh it's okay to discriminate against
uh black people or latino people you
know you that's your right as a business
okay you can technically do that but i
think it's a bad idea and i think that
vaccine mandates that private businesses
are also a bad idea
uh question for you angela uh
similar to the one i put to ilia but uh
sort of honing in on your argument uh
would would you accept uh a a compromise
whereby if somebody is going to where
the government requires that if you're
going to go somewhere that you either uh
have proof of acts or proof uh that you
don't have covet
uh no but that's better but no
no and why would you oppose that well
i've hugged patient zero at freedom fast
and i've been all over the place and
been exposed to plenty of people who
have covet and here i am without it i
haven't contracted it yet
so why should i be subjected to
a mandate or medical experimentation
when i'm perfectly healthy uh comment
elia on that response
i don't have a lot to say on that except
to say that vaccines by overwhelming
evidence from around the world are shown
to be more effective at both preventing
disease and also preventing
hospitalization and death and all these
other measures like testing masking
and so forth which are both less
effective and more intrusive so i say if
we opt for any restriction at all opt
for the less intrusive one
not the one that's less effective and
actually more of an infringement on
liberty
i see some people are lined up for
questions so please phrase your question
as a question no need to identify
yourself and address the person that
you'd like to answer the question if
there's a person
of that kind
i have a question to professor selman
uh two parts
is it fair to compare
vaccines for polio or flu that have been
around for 50 years have an excellent
track record with the new novel vaccines
mrna technology that has no
really no long-term you know side effect
data that's number one
and number two is uh
you know the data from sweden africa
different places shows very low
mortality rates without vaccinations
how do you account for that
those are two questions check it away
on the second question i don't know
about the data from africa the data from
sweden shows mortality rates comparable
to that elsewhere in europe so you can
say that uh they're not having a
lockdown didn't lead them to have higher
mortality rates than uh european
countries that didn't have lockdown
nonetheless they've had tens of
thousands of people die of dekovid and
almost every one of them
was unvaccinated
on the issue of comparing the current
vaccines to ones from the past i would
say two things
one is uh we are now much better uh
scientists are not me personally of
course the scientists are much better at
testing vaccines than they were 50 or
100 years ago with polio or the smallpox
vaccine and the like second we now
actually have evidence from billions of
people who have taken these vaccines and
the rates of side effects and other
issues are actually smaller long-term
vaccines in the past as for the
long-term point uh my understanding for
again this scientist's view is not mine
is that
the effects of vaccines if they have
negative side effects at all it is
almost always within the first few
months not many years afterwards and i
would add that by your reasoning uh that
people should not have taken the
smallpox vaccine or the polio vaccine or
the measles vaccine in the lake uh
until they had waited decades and that
would of course allow those diseases to
kill many more people over a longer
period of time so it's not my claim to
vaccines either in the past or today are
completely without risk it is rather at
least in some cases the risk is vastly
lower than the risk of letting deadly
contagious diseases spread
oh yeah thank you very much okay
smallpox has much higher mortality rate
than code
on the other hand is more contagious
uh uh
excuse me angela do you have a comment
on uh julia's response oh yes uh if you
play russian roulette there's a five out
of six chance you won't shoot yourself
in the head
uh thankfully it's not mandated though
uh next question could which can you
take it away
um
as we have as you mentioned before
the pro
side here will be more grilled in this
audience and so i will also also ask you
a question you said
the
effect or the benefit of vaccines is
undisputed
we had we are just going towards the end
of a wave that has 250 000 death in the
united states
when we go back to early 2020 we had 150
000
deaths and then
nobody was vaccinated now at least 80
percent of the people who are at risk of
dying
are vaccinated
if the vaccine would actually have an
effect
wouldn't one expect fewer people to die
with the vaccine than without the
vaccine
yeah and you would expect that and that
is exactly what has happened among the
unvaccinated uh the death rates are 10
to 20 times higher than among the
vaccinated and of the 250 000 people
that you mentioned over 90 percent of
them were unvaccinated you look around
the world you see similar results the
death rate uh among the uh vaccinated is
far far lower and it's even more so when
you control for factors like age
because the the the elderly are more at
risk from coving but they're also more
likely to be vaccinated uh and when you
control for that you get an even starker
result uh so yes you would expect that
and that is exactly what we have seen
but we have had a higher death rate
among the unvaccinated from the delta
wave than the original one as i
understand it that's because delta is
vastly more contagious
and therefore spreads to more people
faster
i think it's a nonsensical tour but i
i'm not
commenting on it okay uh comment uh on
ilya's response uh uh or do you wanna
wave comment
i just fundamentally disagree with
everything that ilya's saying about
vaccination i've worked in the medical
industry i spent 40 hours preparing for
this debate my entire life has been
consumed by this stupid thing for the
past two years uh
they're not the vaccines are not keeping
you safer that's it
in general
but my question to you is do you think
that any rights violation no matter how
small is ever justified if the payoff is
large enough
i think that any rights violation if you
are going to try to justify it needs to
be made on an individual case-by-case
basis and that justifying taking away
someone's rights with a sweeping mandate
is uh is terrible and should never be
allowed
do you have a one comment yeah so two
things one is
there there can be situations where we
trade off not just rights against
utility but rights against other rights
uh and a wide range of libertarian
thinkers permit that there is a right to
life and a right to protection against
the attack and like but uh in order to
effectuate that that sometimes requires
restrictions on rights as well i
mentioned the examples of taxation for
the police for the military and the like
and also which are much more severe uh
infringements on liberty than uh
vaccination is uh it's at some level it
has to be true that any such things have
to be done on a case-by-case basis uh
but we can't judge the cases unless we
have a general rule you have to have
some kind of principle by which you
approach the cases and i would maintain
in common with a wide range of other
libertarian thinkers that when you can
have a very large savings of human life
at a very small cost in liberty uh
that's a general rule that should be
applied to particular cases which cases
fall within that that's a matter of
factual dispute you know about the
effectiveness of vaccines how dangerous
the disease is and so forth uh and on
those issues unlike the moral issues on
those issues i think we do have to look
uh to the people who are expert in that
particular field which would due respect
i do not think includes either angela or
myself
uh
next question
uh professor solomon uh
next to the mic please hi
going off of just what you just said um
you you talked about um
how
it the the facts of the matter
will vary on what what the cost benefit
is within a cohort um
for the people
um
to create a vaccine mandate you would
need some kind of regulating body to do
that do you think that
um
do you think that they should be able to
to
decide for those people
which ones
have the cost effect cost benefit
uh that is preferable for them and
how do you think that would apply to
other situations that aren't vaccines
so it's a good question i would say a
couple of things on this one is yes the
general principle applies to other
situations but the fact of the matter is
that there are actually very few other
situations where a mandate that imposes
a small infringement on liberty uh has a
huge payoff and wives saved but in those
few other situations yes most
libertarians not all but most other than
anarchists do accept some functions of
government that impose restrictions on
liberty and sometimes hurt innocent
people but have a larger payoff i
mentioned the examples of having some
kind of law enforcement having national
defense and so forth
i met specifically like a board that
determines whether you are a person who
qualifies for a mandate or not yeah so i
was getting to that uh uh in any kind of
function of government that operates at
all obviously you have to have a system
for determining you know who will bear
the burden how big will it be how big
will the expenditures be and those
systems are routinely fought i meant it
with the police and military also we
have lots of wasteful spending we have
abuses of power and so forth
when you compare however uh vaccine
mandates to even very basic functions of
government that libertarians typically
accept the history of vaccine mandates
is actually uh shows many fewer examples
of abuses than those other areas do
i'm not going to design sort of a
complete institutional framework for
this in the next 30 seconds that i have
i would merely say that
such frameworks both with vaccines and
other issues there should be a
presumption against mandates that's only
overcomeable upon strong evidence
and there should be multiple checks and
balances uh that address the issues it
shouldn't be just up to one small group
of experts uh or one
official make sure make sure the mic is
close to you
i i was saying that there should be a
system of checks and balances so it
shouldn't be up to just one person or
one small group of experts
and the like and i would say the same
thing
with any other coercive policies by
government with the private sector i
would have fewer restrictions and i
think the same thing is also true in the
public sector when uh it's a matter of
imposing a vaccine mandate on
government employees particularly those
who themselves wield coercive authority
over the public and who have to uh have
unwilling contact with members of the
population who can't refuse like police
military firefighters and so on
may i just again jump into the
moderate prerogative and hone in on the
question i put to angela
let's say
if somebody uh shows proof of facts as
you see as you said that doesn't
decisively prove that that person
doesn't have covet because people have
died with it but if somebody has proof
that uh 24-hour proof let's take it and
let's make it easy case that you don't
have covet isn't that just as good
if you if there were that person willing
to provide that proof not just if there
was actual proof uh that was as good as
as being vaxxed and sure uh the problem
is that just as vax vacs
what vaccination does is it greatly
reduces the danger that you pose a risk
it doesn't eliminate it but the same
thing is true with passing a covenant
test a covet test uh you know can be
wrong well precisely then aren't they
equivalent that's the point uh
so no i i don't think they're equivalent
because the effect of a vaccination uh
lasts for months at least whereas the
effect of a test uh you could pass the
test today but still have well we talked
about 24 hours the question was a
24-hour proof and and obviously the vax
as you said means that you could still
have covert it uh because people die
have problems i'm sorry and so could
they test well of course that's why they
may be equivalent correct
in theory yes in practice the coercive
apparatus needed to
force people to test every 24 hours is
first i think probably impossible at
least in the us and second obviously
vastly more intrusive uh than getting a
shot even if you get the shot uh every
few months or every year i would add by
the way that contrary to what angela
said they're actually a number lots of
vaccines out there where you get
periodic boosters uh mmr is a well-known
example measles mumps and rubella next
question
the the american government has spent 40
billion dollars to reduce the amount of
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
in my mind my background in physics
this is the most absurd thing any
government has ever done
you talk about carbon dioxide or
vaccination
i'm talking about i wonder what their
opinions are on global warming
i'm afraid
that's a very good question but for
another debate
so uh next question please no
no
good evening thank you both for coming
um
numbers aside individual liberties aside
can you both speak to the general
degradation in science that's been kind
of happening for a long time now i mean
it's become almost religious that you
know we don't seem to reason anymore i
don't know what's going on it's kind of
sad
the general the general degradation of
science uh do you want uh do you want to
help uh answer that first angel and then
and they knew that academia has been
incredibly politicized uh i believe that
it is largely controlled by people who
lean left politically
and that influences medicine and we have
to be pc in medicine now and it is
controlled by you know a particular
political party and that is unfortunate
i do think that it is degraded and i
believe that information about it is
also suppressed especially if you watch
a lot of cnn or msnbc you're not going
to think the same thing that i think
about medicine and it's unfortunate that
it takes so much arguing and researching
just to get to the truth about health
and wellness
uh comment yeah yeah so is there pc bias
in academia yes most academics are
left-wing uh so when you have an issue
that splits experts along right versus
left wines then yes you might be
suspicious that uh if there's more
experts on one side on the other then
that's just because because there's more
left-wing people in academia than
right-wing people
the issue of the effectiveness of
vaccines however is not one actually to
split scientists among or right versus
left wines uh libertarian or
conservative scientists don't have
noticeably different uh opinions on that
question uh from more left-wing ones uh
and uh more generally in the hard
sciences i think there is less political
bias than in the humanities or the
social sciences and the like that's not
to say that you could never have sort of
seemingly hard science conclusions
that get established because of some
sort of political bias
but if so i would want to see the proof
of that a particular area like this one
where there's actually a pretty broad
cross-ideological agreement
among the people who are actually
experts in this particular field
i know well yeah what do you want to
make it's not even the politics it's the
pursuit of truth the scientific method
seems irrelevant nowadays it's it's just
blindly in the blind
so
i'm not a scientist but as far as i can
tell among people who do do scientific
research i think they use the scientific
method at least as well today as in the
past if anything of modern experimental
techniques and technologies and the like
are actually better than those of
decades ago that's certainly true in the
social sciences with which i'm more
familiar with modern research for
instance in economics has better
experimental methods than was the case
40 or 50 years ago my guess is that
that's true in the hard sciences as well
but i have to admit i don't know as much
about that as i i do about the social
sciences next question next question
um i'll just begin by saying uh social
division in the country and censorship
has made it so difficult for people to
talk to each other so thank you all
three of you for putting this on it's
great to have a free exchange of ideas
you're very welcome i got a couple for
professor stowman um uh you made it very
clear that uh you have a nuanced
position you're only defending some
mandates not all mandates including a
mandate uh given by the private sector
so just to clarify what is your position
on president biden's executive order
requiring private companies to issue
vaccine mandates yeah so i've i've
actually written on this it has a number
of legal problems which have written
about it uh perhaps in a different form
i could talk about them but one of the
problems is i think that the uh you know
the the the
the agency osha has exceeded its mandate
i also think that uh you know the the
order fails to make a lot of
distinctions that should be made about
uh you know the could reason we made
about sort of risks and different kinds
of workplace settings uh and further i
think deputizing private employers to
enforce this uh is itself a burden that
is problematic when there are other
better pathways that could be adopted uh
that would not uh create such a burden
uh and i mentioned several of them
already conditioning welfare or tax
benefits uh enforcing mandates only in
places where you already have to show an
id to get in somewhere and to like so
i think that particular order for
private employees i think is legally
dubious and in fact one court has
already ruled against it and policy wise
it's not a great idea on the other hand
i do support his vaccination mandates
for most federal employees and
especially for the armed forces
and i think there is a case to be made
although here you know there are some
complexities but there's a pretty good
case to be made for uh the mandate that
he has imposed on uh medical uh
institutions that receive uh federal uh
grants i
related question to you about the the
mandates imposed just uh the other day
by the mayor de blasio of new york city
on private uh sector and private do you
have the same view same dubious view
pretty much uh i don't know whether
they're are legal problems that are
similar and that i just don't know much
about the laws of new york state and how
much you know legal authority de blasio
has but as a mechanism of enforcement i
think is problematic uh and uh you know
for some of the same reasons as the uh
the biden uh national mandate is coming
from you uh
yeah i don't believe that you should
have to choose between being homeless
and destitute or taking a shot that you
may not need or that might hurt you i
think that's a bad move yeah
uh next question i just have one more
for professor zoman uh if you are in
favor of covet mandates during this time
of a pandemic what is the precise
standard that is a measurable numerical
metric to be reached for our society to
discontinue all the covet mandates is it
a certain percentage of the population
vaccinated uh a certain percentage with
coveted antibodies or an average covert
death rate or comparable to regular flu
what
yeah
so i don't know that i'm capable of
saying this should be the exact precise
line uh my point is that they're going
to be some cases which fall easily on
one side of the line or the other and
the current situation sadly with a
highly contagious pandemic with
thousands of people still dying and the
threat of new variants being developed
if a vaccination a higher vaccination
rate isn't reached i think easily falls
along on the side of the line where at
least some mandates are justified
i think
what the point at which it could be
stopped will depend in part on various
scientific facts such as uh you know
what will be the transmissibility of the
dominant variant
and some others as well but i would add
also that it's true you could get this
wrong and have it last too long just as
you could
have it last long enough uh one reason
why i worry less about this than with
other coercive measures
is because this is a
very modest degree of coercion for the
reasons that i mentioned earlier
that said there should always be a
presumption in favor of liberty
and therefore if we get to a point where
things are hazy and it's unclear then i
would sort of so to speak break the tie
against having more mandates rather in
favor of them uh comment angela yeah oh
do you want to make a comment i hope we
have an end in sight at some point
right
angela comment no okay okay uh this will
have to be the final question uh so uh
get laid on us
awesome thank you both for being here um
my question is for angela um stepping
away from the current covid situation we
find ourselves in if theoretically there
were a very different disease with say a
much higher mortality rate and
no or very few antiviral treatments
available but there were a vaccine that
greatly reduced lethality do you think a
mandate could ever be justified in a
scenario like that
i don't
and i don't think that it would be
necessary i think that if we saw
something that was really deadly
visceral like a science fiction horror
movie we would all be staying at home we
would not be going to the grocery store
and ordering from grubhub and still you
know trying to go about our lives and
parties we would all be staying home and
terrified
and i don't ever believe that it's okay
to mandate experimental treatments and
there are no mid or long-term studies on
the the kovid shot yet and so
i would say that that the same thing
should apply for something that's more
deadly we should not subject people to
medical experimentation against their
will
uh thank you for the question yeah and
now we have to uh we have to wrap it up
and go to summary i i want to want to
make it clear that neither of the that
all three none of these people on the
stage has
said that they are not vaccinated that
no such statement has been made by
anybody on the stage if there was an
implication to that effect then uh that
was unfortunate
it was unintended nobody on this stage
has said that they are not vaccinated uh
not me not angela and not ilya
so uh please let make that clear uh to
the audience and uh uh to those who are
listening uh all right uh we have a
final uh summation uh and uh that will
come from yulia five minutes to
summarize i'll take i'll sit down and
you can check the podium
i'm not sure that there's a lot to be
added to what's already been said so
just make a couple of very basic points
one is that this is a broader debate
about the nature of vaccine mandates
generally not just very specific
policies that exist today and i would
add that it is not the case that vaccine
mandates for other diseases only existed
200 years ago or 100 years ago we still
have them for measles for
other things as well and one reason why
we still keep measles at bay is because
we have a high vaccination rate for it
and the same is true for a number of
other deadweak contagious diseases so
the history of vaccination uh for at
least seventies deadweed contagious
disease is one of great success in
reducing death rates so much that we
barely even think about most of these
other diseases anymore in part because
of the enormous success
of vaccination secondly i can understand
a point of view which perhaps angela has
or some others have you know if she
doesn't uh that you could never have
coercion for anything anywhere if that's
true then we wouldn't help government at
all and
then we would have a much larger debate
about government versus anarchy which
certainly rages in libertarian circles
from time to time
but if you agree with sort of even the
standard list of minimal functions of
government that those libertarians who
are not anarchists except like national
defense police protection uh and some
others as well all of those actually
pose much greater risk to liberty and
require greater sacrifices through
taxation and other restrictions
than the vaccination mandates of the
kind that i have been talking about
so
i think
if you reject them even in these
scenarios where there is a big trade-off
in terms of saving large numbers of
lives of very little cost then you have
to bite a large number of other bullets
which if you're an anarchist you may
well be willing to bite but otherwise
i think that you should not
the next point i would make is about
evidence on the covet vaccines and their
effectiveness and the like as i've said
before this is not my area of expertise
it seems to me that it is not actually
angela's area of expertise either she
may have worked in the medical industry
but she's not an epidemiologist she's
not a specialist in this area uh so uh
on these kinds of technical questions i
think the best we can do is follow the
general consensus or the dominant view
of the people who are experts in this
area especially when they tend to agree
with each other across ideological lines
as i mentioned earlier it might be a
different situation if you saw will
left-wing experts believe the vaccines
are effective whereas right-wing ones
think they're not then we might say
we're in the presence of sort of
ideological bias motivating people the
subject of ideological bias is when we
am somewhat of an expert have a book
called democracy and political ignorance
where i go into this at some length uh
this is not one of those areas where the
experts are divided along ideological
lines it's one where they're pretty
firmly uh
one side
and
finally i would say this that when we're
looking at policy in the real world and
we face trade-offs we do not currently
have a libertarian government we're not
likely to have one any time soon if you
have a deadweed contagious disease
spreading uh with little or no check
that government is going to take various
kinds of harsh measures
vaccine mandates
are much less restrictive and much more
effective than some of these other
things which can be done and as i
mentioned earlier with the delta wave
which happened during a period of
vaccination precisely because we had the
vaccines available we saw much less in
the way of other much worse coercive
measures than we did uh in 2020 there
was much less in a way of lockdowns much
less in the way of school closures much
less in the way of travel restrictions
and so on and so forth uh and with a
higher vaccination rate we could benefit
from that beneficial trade-off still
more we still do have some measures in
place which are unjust in which i oppose
like mask mandates
like some uh reverse the travel ban on
people from africa and some other uh
things as well
but we can get rid of that in part by
promoting uh greater vaccination
and
the final very final point is simply
that
this is a limited resolution
and my purpose is to defend some vaccine
mandates not all or even perhaps most
the basic idea is that we should accept
them in the limited cases where they
save large numbers of lives at very
little cost
whether it be costs in utilitarian terms
or cost to liberty i think that's
something that libertarians can and do
accept in other contexts and we should
accept it here as well thank you so much
and thank you for coming and for taking
part in this uh exciting debate
thank you
five minutes of rebuttal of a summary
for you angela
i oppose these mandates from a
libertarian and a utilitarian
perspective i will remind you that
actually this is something that you
should be encouraged by the reason that
smallpox is not so prevalent today is
not just because of a vaccination it's
because it continued to mutate until it
turned into the variolu strain and it
became less deadly and less harmful and
so maybe that's what omicron persei 8 is
about to do for everyone so take heart
i am so sorry about what's happened to
the city of new york it is really
heartbreaking to see
and uh it's one of the reasons that i
oppose mandates
we'll never bring sherry back
the dead 13 year old girl her mother
will never hold her again
she'll never pet her dog go to prom or
college
get married
make memories
with her own children and
that goes for for everyone who died from
these shots and these mandates andrew
nadeau uh of long island uh is uh he's a
riverhead school board candidate an
experienced naval corpsman who's treated
thousands of coveted patients and has
personally recovered from covet he's
being forced out of the navy right now
because he's refusing the covet shot
in his refusal letter to his commanding
officer he cited the nuremberg code and
said human experimentation is only
permissible if it satisfies basic
principles of moral ethical and legal
concepts the nuremberg code states the
voluntary consent of the human subject
is absolutely essential
this means the person involved should
have legal capacity to give consent
in his letter he went on to quote c.s
lewis
c.s lewis states of all tyrannies
a tyranny exercised for the good of its
victims
may be the most oppressive
those who torment us for our own good
will torment us without end
for they do so with the approval of
their own conscience
if we stay on this path
where you go what you eat what you put
in your body your biometric markers what
you speak who you speak to will all be
monitored
for your own good right according to
government edicts your liberty will
cease and you will be safe according to
government standards
but eventually that feeling of safety
will slip away
as you realize you've been caged
because the inside of a government cage
is a very unsafe place
good times make weak men
weak men make bad times and bad times
make strong men
we are entering bad times
and we desperately need strong men
as a country we've culturally rejected
being the hero of our own story
instead we've gone back inside plato's
cave
many americans have just rejected
courage and rejected truth
we've become unwilling to fight to
preserve our liberty politicians openly
mock us for wanting freedom
people go on msnbc and say things that
embarrass a lot of libertarians
it's a republic if you can keep it we
put up with taxation we complained about
the patriot act we complained about tsa
we protested lockdowns but we didn't
truly fight back
so the time to fight back is now
now
lots of people value security over
freedom but there's no security in
allowing a despotic police state to
dictate how you live your life if we
keep going down this path we will end up
in a fusion of communism and fascism
it's better to be secure in your
convictions then place your faith in
totalitarian edicts or policy wonks
every single one of you can make a
difference every single person in this
room can do it work up the courage to
say no be brave it's easier to fight for
this on the streets than it is from
inside a prison cell or a gulag for
anyone who says they're not strong
enough to stand up to this stuff i say
yes you are you are strong enough and
you're not giving yourself enough credit
it grieves me to see la and new york
city destroyed by these mandates i'm a
city person
i love city living i love crowds
nightlife hustle in your face humanity
of this beautiful city i love it
does anybody know zinkichi restaurant
with the little train cars shut down
vice of ice gone forever
people have abandoned this city because
of government edicts they've ruined it
even michael malus is gone a new york
city treasure
what the government has done here is
wrong and what they've done to you all
is wrong
how do societies lose their freedom
one little sin at a time you go to work
someone's lording their cubicle
authority over you someone's tyrannical
and you don't have the wherewithal to
stand up to them you see someone else
being bullied or censored medical
information censored and you don't have
the backbone to stand up for them
government thugs rob you of your income
lock you in your home force you to get
vaccinated if you want to keep your job
you roll over it's like okay you're a
slave and if you continue to be a slave
you will continue to generate tyrants
but the good news
is that there are more of us than there
are of them and if we work together we
can overturn these mandates
gene has taken a lot of heat for
continuing to hold debates in a venue
that enforces mandates instead of giving
him grief on social media we need to
help him we need to overturn these
mandates focus your energy on fighting
this thing and building each other up
not tearing each other down
we are having an organizing call on
thursday the 16th specifically to over
to your new york city's mandates i am
going to help you guys through
initiative get involved let's unite and
do this these mandates do not make us
freer or safer let's reclaim our
humanity and oppose medical mandates
thank you
well
jane please open the voting and so now
we have to uh uh get the results of the
voting
and uh thank you uh
drum roll please um i forgot to bring
the tootsie roll so i'm sorry about that
but i'll be rewarding it later to
whoever uh okay while vaccine mandates
are an infringement on freedom some are
justified due to their big payoff in
life saved that was defended by ilya
ilya you began with 15.85 percent of the
vote and you ended with 28
that means you've picked up 12.2 points
congratulations elia i'm picking up 12.2
points that's the number to beat um now
angela began with 52.44
and ended with 67
so she nosed you out by 2.4 percentage
points uh not a huge win angela but you
do get the crunch the tootsie roll
congratulations angela
and congratulations to you both thank
you